il ya exactement dix ans dans un
amphithéâtre de la prestigieuse
université de californie à los angeles
ucla
au cours d'une classe de management j'ai
entendu les mots qui ont changé ma
perception de moi même ces mots étaient
les termes vision et leadership
il ya exactement un an dans les
caniveaux de la ville d'abidjan
j'ai pu commencer à vivre ces deux mots
vision et leadership
je suis jianghuai je suis une mère je
suis une campagne je suis cadre dans une
société
je suis une citoyenne de tout ce qu'il
ya de plus ordinaire et je suis une
avant-gardiste
je suis une avant-gardiste parce que je
fais partie de la mode team l'âme au
team est un rassemblement de citoyens
ordinaires qui se sont mis ensemble
parce qu'après avoir constaté en
regardant autour d'eux la perte de nos
valeurs telles que le civisme la
discipline la solidarité ont décidé de
leur place d' apporter du positif dans
nos communautés parmi vous qui a une
vision
ok parmi vous qui pensent que le
leadership n'est pas réservé à une
catégorie spéciale de personnes je suis
ravi de voir que j'ai beaucoup de
leaders dans la salle nous sommes en
famille en fait dans nos sociétés dans
l'inconscient collectif
ici en côte d'ivoire mais pas dans cette
salle parce qu'il ya beaucoup de leaders
généralement le leader c'est le
politicien ou celui qui a beaucoup
d'argent ou encore beaucoup de diplôme
ou même une star espère sont des leaders
ou quelqu'un qui vient d'un background
social promis nan mais il n'en est rien
parce que la réalité c'est que le
leadership c'est le processus par lequel
une personne ou un groupe de personnes
influence positivement d'autres
personnes pour l'accomplissement d'un
objectif commun de par cette définition
c'est que chacun d'entre nous est un
leader ou à la possibilité d'être un
leader c'est sur cette assertion que la
mode team s'est créée voilà notre joli
logo il y a donc un an avec une amie sur
cette photo diaby aïcha dionne nous
avons décidé d'initier ce qu'on a appelé
les 52 semaines d'action citoyenne
nous nous sommes dit que chaque samedi
systématiquement nous sortirions de chez
nous pour nettoyer les caniveaux du
lundi au vendredi nous travaillons je
suis à edf
aïcha et digital manager mais nous avons
décidé que les samedis nous enfilons
riant des bottes des gants et nous
descendre et ainsi pour pouvoir
descendre dans les caniveaux et pendant
que nous sommes dans les caniveaux
il s'agit pour nous de parler à nos
concitoyens les riverains les passants
les vendeurs sur la nécessité pour
chacun de nous de faire preuve de
civisme et de prendre soin de notre
environnement
nous nous sommes inspirés de celui que
nous appelons président adama keïta il
est le président c'est un jeune de
treichville il est le président de luan
gmail on business
il a réalisé quelque chose de
fantastique à treichville la rue 11 à 13
villes c'est sa rue la rue il a grandi
il a pu organiser mobiliser la
population afin que ces populations
chaque week end ensemble des toits les
rues de leur communauté
et quand il a commencé cette initiative
après la crise qu'a connue notre pays
cette initiative a permis à des gens qui
ne s'étaient plus parlé depuis la crise
postélectorale de s'adresser à nouveau
la parole au fur et à mesure du temps
d'autres citoyens ordinaires nous ont
rejoints nous avons des cadres
nous avons des chômeurs nous avons des
étudiants nous avons des ménagères nous
avons toutes les couches de la société
ce qui nous lie c'est notre vision le
changement par l'action citoyenne à
travers le bénévolat
notre devise est un jour abidjan sera
comme kigali
pourquoi kigali me direz vous pourquoi
pas new york ou los angeles que moi même
je connais si bien ou melbourne ou même
tokyo pourquoi kigali kigali à cause du
rwanda le rwanda d'abord c'est un pays
africains comme le nôtre et ensuite
c'est l'un des pays qui a connu l'une
des crises du moins l'un des génocides
les plus atroces de l'histoire de
l'humanité mais un moment ses fils et
ses filles ont pris sur eux pour
reconstruire leur pays pour retrouver
leurs valeurs et aujourd'hui kigali est
réputée être la ville la plus propre
d'afrique un jour abidjan sera comme
kigali
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes dans les caniveaux et nous
faisant appeler les ducs et les
duchesses des caniveaux aujourd'hui j'ai
essayé de m'habiller comme une duchesse
ton bien que mal mais les samedis voilà
ce que je fais je suis dans les ordures
[Applaudissements]
nous avons eu à aller dans des endroits
qu'on n'aurait pas imaginé qu'il puisse
avoir autant de saleté nous sommes allés
dans des écoles nous avons pu enlever
dans une école 120 tonnes de déchets
donc littéralement nos enfants
apprennent dans les déchets cette
génération cette jeunesse cette
génération que nous sommes censés former
pour être la relève
sachez qu'elle apprend dans les déchets
cette image est dans une école et notre
action se base essentiellement sur une
valeur le bénévolat
malheureusement à l'heure actuelle le
bénévolat n'est pas une valeur que
d'abord qui est connu ici dans notre
pays et beaucoup niveau ne voit pas
vraiment l'importance du bénévolat
et pourtant nos sociétés africaines se
basait sur le bénévolat sur la
solidarité
il n'était pas rare de voir des paysans
défricher le champ du voisin
nous venons d'avoir un exemple avec
daniel défricher le champ du voisin
aujourd'hui et la semaine d'après on
défriche ensemble le champ d'un autre
voisin ainsi de suite c'est du bénévolat
c'est de la solidarité
aujourd'hui nous nous disons que écoute
c'est le modernisme
ça c'est dans le village on ne fait plus
ah oui effectivement nous ne faisons
plus à même au point de ne plus nous
saluer sur nos lieux de résidence n'est
pas rare de voir des voisins ne pas se
saluer bon bref
mais ce que je voudrais dire moi qui ai
vécu longtemps aux etats unis c'est que
les états unis
qui est la première puissance mondiale
ont érigé le bénévolat au rang de valeur
nationale c'est aux états unis que j'ai
appris le bénévolat quand j'étais ayew
ciel et je faisais partie d'une
organisation bénévole qui s'appelait
project angel food
il s'agissait pour cette organisation il
s'agit pour cette organisation parce
qu'elle existe toujours de faire de la
nourriture pour les personnes vivant
avec des maladies graves telles que le
cancer le sida et des personnes à très
peu revenu et dans cette organisation il
y avait des stars il y avait des
politiciens que vous connaissez que vous
avez l'habitude de voir à la télé ils
étaient là tous ensemble en faisait la
cuisine et bénévolement
on distribue sncc paquet repas qu'on
faisait aux différentes familles
affectées et donc c'est pour vous dire
que pour construire une société unie des
communautés unis nous avons besoin du
bénévolat nous avons besoin de faire ces
choses pour lesquelles on ne demande
rien en retour
c'est cela qui consolide qui assure la
cohésion d'une communauté je ne vais pas
être longue et vous dire que pour ce qui
concerne la mode team chaque samedi
il est important pour nous d'être
quelque part dans la ville et de faire
notre part parce que c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit
chacun d'entre nous à quelque chose à
donner à sa communauté
même un sourire c'est redonner à la
communauté
est ce que nous faisons peut-être
certains diront que c'est pas grand
chose mais nous n'avons pas la
prétention de nous substituer aux
pouvoirs publics
nous savons juste qu'en tant que
citoyens responsables
il est de notre devoir de nous saisir
d'une des problématiques de notre
société de nos communautés et d'apporter
notre part et ce bénévolement
donc chaque samedi dans les ordures
pendant des heures dans la poussière et
la boue
le message qu'on veut lancer à nos
concitoyens c'est regarde autour de toi
regarde ta communauté
je suis sûr qu'il ya des
dysfonctionnements dans ta communauté je
suis sûr que il y a des problèmes dans
ta communauté qui t'interpelle
personnellement peut-être qu'il est
temps pour toi que le leader qui en toi
c'est veille que le leader qui en toi
décide de s'approprier de l'une de ces
problématiques et toi de ta place avec
tes moyens faire ta part apporté sa
contribution
combien de jeunes sont dans nos
quartiers sans modèle sans repères
pourtant certains d'entre nous sont des
cadres sont des jeunes entrepreneurs
sont des start up heures pourquoi ne pas
consacrer ne serait ce qu'une heure dans
la semaine à quelques jeunes deux ou
trois pour leur parler de leadership ou
leur parler de vision
vous leur parlez de tout ce dont nous
sommes en train de parler ici pourquoi
ne pas porter ça dans la rue dans nos
communautés c'est ce que nous faisons
alamo petit ces messages qu'on entend
dans les conférences nous les portons
dans la rue d'abobo à 13 villes en
passant par port bouet gonzagueville
nous avons porté ce message nous avons
porté le message aux populations leur
disant vous n'êtes pas un puissant il
faut refuser d'être impuissant le simple
fait de s'abaisser de ramasser un papier
le simple fait de prendre soin de son
environnement immédiat fait de chacun de
ces personnes un leader calame optim
nous ne faisons pas de suiveurs ou le
disons toujours nous nous créons des
leaders c'est ce que nous faisons est
donc chacun d'entre vous
vous pouvez dès avant gardiste
je ne vous demande pas de rejoindre un
mot team je vous demande de retourner
dans vos communautés ce soir après cette
conférence de jeter un regard nouveau
sur ce qui vous entoure et de voir où
est ce que je peux exercer cette avant
garde et devenir un avant gardiste un
leader je vous remercie
merci diane douanes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]